foreign
[Music]
[Music]
it's really pretty I think this is the
beach they uh I'm not sure
but I think they shot the Olympics here
it's really pretty really big waves a
little too big for me but I wrote a
couple at least so I'm very happy I'm
very stoked as they say God it's such a
workout
oh yeah look at that
they do that have the Olympic thing I
gotta check it out hell yeah
this has Pokemon gym feel
that's so cool
foreign
[Music]
this is the level we're at with my
she wants me to hand feed her otherwise
she gets really mad
hmm
you know what's going on in you is there
any Halloween costume
you look good
we're in chofu
it's a pretty cool area
I'm gonna check out some places and
maybe do some pottery stuff it's nice I
like it very pretty everything is so
Japanese
[Music]
I don't know what that is
evil
[Music]
you can eat the cup
[Music]
[Laughter]
was good oh good yeah
[Music]
so we're gonna do Pottery you get to
pick which one and then you paint it I
think I'll go for the cupboard
we're doing what's it called raka Yaki
traditional Japanese pottery Brown and
low temperature
[Music]
no
mistakes for me
all right
there he is oh God
[Music]
look at this
ice cream
oh my God
hey guy come here I want to show you
guys Edgar are you
right there
are you looking for
hey Gary you looking for trouble
trouble
I'm going to get Marcia a present it's
her birthday tomorrow
she thinks I'm going to the arcade to
play games
what a fool I've already bought her a
gift but it's her third idea
so I want to give her something nice
we'll see how this goes
[Music]
we're celebrating Mars's birthday
so I'm not vlogging much but uh just
wanted to show it looks so pretty damn
unreal look at that
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
this hotel is insane
and then there's like a view
this is the coolest hotel lobby I've
ever seen
so tired
such a long drive but it's such a nice
day
I forgot to film The View
it's over there
which is nice
[Music]
we're in uh Chiba again it's my birthday
tomorrow so I'm going to surf we stopped
by this place I don't know how to
describe it I'll just show it they have
all new and old trains
you having fun Iggy
this is the first trip we take in Japan
with Maya
[Music]
oh wow so I haven't got your pods in
here of trains I'm so over gotcha what
it's the Yen coin gotcha that is so
weird I kind of I want that one
it's almost November and it's 25 degrees
they sell drinks in here
[Music]
what a view here
don't you love it Maya there you go
train nerds
you're welcome oh yeah back in the day
no AC huh
damn
[Music]
oh okay
yes
[Music]
the last Scotch I'll ever buy Marta got
it from me at least there's no
there's tape
yes
oh it has a battery
so something must happen now it's on
I just lights up that's cool
here we are got our backyard
and there's a lake
people fishing
backwards
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
he's an all-class against Sweden it's my
birthday happy birthday to me
yeah 33.
damn we're going to check out some local
stuff some cool scenery that looks like
a British break and then surf
[Music]
you know what I guarantee there's a
treasure there I played enough Uncharted
to know looks like you can go there but
that looks very dangerous
foreign
that's so pretty
we decided to go to another Beach the
weather's nice but the waves aren't so
might do a little bit here
then head back
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
that was nice
heading to
back to surigasaki hopefully there's
better ways there there were earlier
today
so we'll see
here in Chima there's so many abandoned
buildings
this is massive bowling alley
completely abandoned
but there's so many new ones as well
it's really odd I guess no one bowls
anymore crazy how much more intense does
it look
are you worried again
[Music]
we are at
you will never guess this
guess now
we're in Sweden we're at the Bonsai
Museum sorry that was a good meme
that's a big ass Bonsai then we have to
watch water sign every time from
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
to get the view wow that is actually
awesome
we were recognized so there was insanely
kind to us and they gave us all these
gifts so kind
[Music]
was not expecting that since they
recognized us they were so sweet
everyone's so nice they gave us tea they
gave us treats they signed the book yeah
I recommend checking it out everyone was
so nice when they spoke really good
English too so if you're into bonsai
come to Bonsai Museum
[Music]
I have to move my uh
we're going to Disneyland
and you get to dress up
you know
I bought a Jedi costume
like 300 bucks that was gonna look like
Obi-Wan so cool
this is my outfit so cute
they look amazing
[Music]
got a couple of rides
it's nice we're lucky with the weather
feels really good it's really bizarre
being at Disneyland in Japan because
I don't know it just feels extra layer
of trippy I guess like Japan is trippy
enough and then you go to Disneyland
here and this is weird
that was such a fun day
aren't you glad you came along
sorry I didn't Vlog anything is this I
know I can't really film on the rides
and what's going on with my hair
sometimes it's nice not to Vlog I guess
it's really really fun though I almost
lost my voice because I screamed so much
I'm gonna head back to the buggy